from one social media to another uh
florida congresswoman
cat mcca cat kamek sending a scathing
letter to facebook after reportedly
finding
ads for human smugglers and cartels on
the platform
she wrote in part facebook's role in the
crisis
at the border is urgent and must be
addressed immediately
as people visited these pages myself
included facebook then provided
additional
pages and posts of related illegal
content
congresswoman kamik is a member of the
homeland security committee she joins us
right now from florida
congresswoman good morning good morning
steve how are you doing i'm doing okay
thank you very much so we were talking
about this story yesterday
you go down to our southern border you
see with your own two eyes you talk to
the migrants about how they heard about
coming there
and then you hear all about facebook the
cartels
are buying ads on facebook
it's wild it is absolutely
unconscionable to think that this is
happening
but i got to tell you my very first
border trip we had just gotten to the
donna processing facility
and there was a busload of
very young children and parents with
children under the age of six and i
spoke to
a 15 year old girl i said where are you
from she said guatemala i said how did
you know to come here
and she said facebook i hadn't been but
five minutes
in the donna processing facility when i
heard the term
facebook and as i went through the
facility i kept hearing from kids
from adults facebook yes we coordinated
logistics through facebook we paid
through facebook we talked on whatsapp
which is owned by facebook
and it was a disturbing trend and when i
started talking with hsi
and some of the border patrol agents
they themselves have seen this firsthand
so
i figure hey i'm a millennial i'm pretty
savvy with facebook
i'll do a quick search and just this
morning you know at six o'clock as i'm
sitting down to do
this this interview with you guys i pull
up viaje uh
and lo and behold a page with directions
with routes prices six grand to come to
the united states
9 300 to get to san antonio it takes
a simple search of get to the front
and that is all it takes to find out
exactly who to pay
how to get here and how you're going to
get smuggled across and they even talk
about in these ads
how you can take a six-year-old or under
or if you're a single adult what they're
going to do to help get you across
it's absolutely nuts it is nuts be and
they know that if you've got a kid
they're going to let the kid in and they
might let you in as well
but here's the thing and you've written
a letter to
facebook and you've written a letter to
mark zuckerberg to say hey
look what you're doing but think about
it
this means that facebook is making
money from cartels and from human
smugglers
how can they do that it's absolutely i
mean
27 billion dollars is what facebook made
in the first quarter of this year
now i'm not saying that that's all
cartel money right but they are
advertising on social media but then if
you look in my own home district
i have a little mom and pop shop owned
by the lrads they sell homemade jellies
and they were banned from selling
advertisements on facebook
because they had been flagged for
conservative content
i have a single mom in ocala who owns a
video production company and she's been
banned from selling ads on facebook
because she posted a picture of herself
in a maga hat this
is unconscionable so my my question to
mark zuckerberg and the folks at
facebook
instead of targeting conservatives maybe
we should focus on the cartels instead
right yeah no kidding well let's see
what they do i know that after you wrote
your letter it was a big
story and yet you just did a search 37
minutes ago
and the ads are still there that it's
just yeah
congresswoman before you go we were
talking a moment ago about earmarks uh
so are you one of the republican
congress people who have signed up for
more government cash for your district
no i can say that i am proud to have
voted against earmarks and stood firm
against them
washington's got a spending problem uh
not a saving
problem so i think i can better serve my
constituents by working to recover money
that's already owed to them through
federal agencies rather than spending
more of their hard-earned tax dollars
there you go
all right congresswoman kat kamek
joining us from gainesville
thank you very much for joining us live
there was some concern whether or not i
would pronounce her last name correctly
and i think i did at the end
all right thank you congresswoman